if you thought Donald Trump's 2016
promises about a wall on the southern
border that Mexico would pay for a
beautiful new health care plan ending
the israeli-palestinian conflict and all
of that stuff was unrealistic if you
thought that was far-fetched the stuff
that Trump is increasingly promising if
he were to become president in 2024 is
even more outrageous and it includes
flying cars I know I know I it's it's
truly a stunning thing but that's what
Trump is talking about there's an uh
exclusive Politico article Trump calls
for contest to create futuristic Freedom
cities which says modern cities and
flying cars might sound like the makings
of an episode of The Jetsons where a
fictionalized family flew around in
orbit City for former president Donald
Trump it's the foundation of a new set
of futuristic policy proposals in a
video set to be released Friday Trump
call for a Quantum Leap in the American
standard of living
he already talked about those Freedom
cities during his CPAC speech which was
pretty unhinged and basically sort of
like a camp for homeless people and
Trump also is talking about
technological elements in another
political article it uh sort of expands
on the flying car's idea Trump calling
for massive investment in vertical
takeoff and Landing Vehicles also known
as flying cars there is something really
interesting here now first and foremost
the Wright loves to say that the left
promise is unrealistic things the things
the left promises are only unrealistic
insofar as Republicans are unwilling to
actually fund them and insist that
they're not things worth worth uh worth
doing including trying to get everybody
health care or whatever the case may be
one of the really interesting thing
about flying cars is that it's very easy
to visualize it when you talk about well
we're going to
um work hard to change the way that we
power our homes and cars so it's
increasingly from wind and Sun rather
than well listen you've I flipped on a
light bulb I don't know it turned on it
doesn't feel that different if the
source changes from being coal to being
solar or whatever the case may be and
because it's less visual it also doesn't
really sound that worthwhile to put any
money into it okay so flying cars
extraordinarily visual the other thing
is that Trump does have this tendency to
get obsessed with something without
really understanding it you might
remember where there were a few speeches
Trump gave I think this was in 2020
where he became focused on going to Mars
even if he called it Nars the United
States will be the first nation to land
an astronaut on ours okay I I remember
it like it was yesterday so Trump does
get fixated on some of this futuristic
stuff as well
um but the flying cars the inclusion of
flying cars is uh is is pretty damn
interesting now flying cars are also
interesting because of the cultural
um importance of flying cars flying cars
have been a sort of microcosm or
emblematic of the future is now here and
if you look at things that were written
uh in the 30s and 40s and certainly you
look at sci-fi in the 50s and 60s lots
of the things that Arthur C Clarke wrote
about 50 years ago have happened
satellites and different things but
flying cars as a sort of ubiquitous
staple of the futuristic Society has not
developed nearly as quickly as some
imagined that it would and there's a lot
of different reasons for that one is if
you're going to have flying cars
they've got to be really really safe and
of course drone technology the sort of
quadcopter type technology
um might offer some of the redundancies
that would be needed for really safe
flying cars but also listen every time
I'm on the highway there's someone in
the fast lane going 57 while on a cell
phone I don't know that I want to put
those people in the air anytime soon and
so until the self-driving technology
really matures flying cars aren't going
to be happening anytime soon but the
inclusion of it is certainly interesting
so a lot of cultural stuff to talk about
when we talk about flying cars and it is
really interesting Trump promising
flying cars between 2025 and 2029 that
is not a realistic promise as I'm sure
most of you realize
if you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below